is that when these schools of IDI these
self-styled scholars who really don't
appear to be able to do any kind of
analysis that's worth the worth the word
analysis moved in and started training
the generations teachers what they in
part did with this with this embrace of
post post modernist and even pseudo post
modernist thought was elevate the idea
of white-collar work much of which is
meaningless and pointless and doesn't
need to be done and throughout the value
of and the the idea that there was
virtue and honour in blue-collar work
and in so doing they a you know
guaranteed that there are a lot of
people who had been voting Democratic
we're not going to anymore if you know
if if people working the trades are no
longer valued because this this post -
garbage coming out of schools of Ed is
now in the Democratic Party as well
which it clearly is some number of
people are going to say well screw that
I'm going to the other party but it it
also reminds us once again of something
that I and we have been saying for a
long time which is that for people who
literally do not do anything that is
physical in the world and therefore have
no thing that they do from which they
can get feedback which cannot be gamed
those people have an easier time fooling
themselves and the rest of the world
about what their true intentions are and
whether or not they're supposed
solutions will work I actually don't
really want to hear from someone who's
who's got proposed solutions if they
can't demonstrate to me that they can do
something in the physical world
successfully and I was actually I was
walking around Oregon City a week ago or
so waiting well our younger son was
having an orthodontist appointment and I
passed by statue outside the local
courthouse I've forgotten the guy's name
but he was some important figure in
Oregon City maybe one of the first
judges an important lawyer and this the
bust of him had all of those things but
the very first thing that it had on the
on the statue in terms of what he did
was welder
and I hope I have this right I hope I
have which trade it was which all these
other things were but I come in as a
Toby her son this appointment I was
waiting on after I said you know isn't
isn't that amazing and wonderful that
they chose to point out first and maybe
was blacksmith like I can't remember
yeah that they chose first and foremost
to identify the trade that he was
skilled in before pointing out the
things that he did that are why his bust
is here you know if he had just been a
blacksmith or weld or whatever it was
that he was doing he wouldn't have a
statue in front of the courthouse right
yeah but I would argue that had he not
had that background in the trade that he
did he also wouldn't have his bust in
front in that courthouse because he
wouldn't have the sense and the wisdom
that those skills gave him in order to
do good in the world later yeah an
incredible amount of what's true is also
counterintuitive to one level or another
and the way you discover that is through
some system in which what is
counterintuitive you are forced to it by
the fact of the system isn't listening
to clever arguments it just works or
doesn't and so yes you and I both have
this sense that it is fundamentally
important before you start deciding what
should happen that you have experience
with some system that is completely
impervious to your cleverness of speech
and only responds to your depth of
insight
[Music]